hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
enrichment
and analysis of rare antigen and
virus-specific t-cells presented by
dr marcelo stein the global product
manager
of t-cell immunology at milton biotech
i am tracy essen-martin of labroots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
miltney biotech for more information on
our sponsor
please visit miltneybiotech.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the
ask box located on the far left of your
screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr marcelo stein
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr stein
you may now begin your presentation
welcome everybody to our webinar
enrichment and analysis of rare antigen
and virus-specific t-cells
in the next 45 minutes you will learn
about miltoni biotech's extensive
antigen-specific and virus-specific
t-cell portfolio including
relevant application data and workflows
so enjoy
let's begin with a brief company
presentation
miltoni biotech was founded in 1989 by
stefan milton himself
and is the largest owner managed company
in germany
we have two main sites in germany one in
berges-gladbach where the headquarters
are located
and one in tether where the gmp
manufacturing facility is located
we have subsidiaries in 28 countries and
additionally distribute in 73
more countries currently we employ over
3 000
employees worldwide our mission is to
serve the needs in life science research
and to translate new scientific findings
into clinical applications
in the current situation with the covet
19 pandemic it has never been more
important to have powerful tools at your
disposal
for an efficient work with antigen or
better in this case virus specific t
cells sarskoff 2 as cause of the novel
respiratory disease cov19
exhibits high infection rates in number
of cases worldwide
with partially severe causes of disease
and even fatalities
this has severe social and economic
consequences
so we need to act now miltoni biotech
does its best to support your
virus-specific t-cell research
let's have a first look on how we can
define angiogen-specific t-cells
of course all t cells are antigen
specific
however that term hereby is applied to t
cells that were activated prior to
analysis via their cognitive antigen and
not by an artificial polyclonal stimulus
hereby only t cells of the given
specificity are activated
and cloningly expand the initial
frequency of a t cell of a certain
specificity is
however very low analysis of
antigen-activated t t-cells is important
to understand the very basics of the
immune response
and plays a pivotal role not only in
infectious diseases
but also in tumor immunology
autoimmunity electrology and many more
a little more detailed look is depicted
on the right side
upon antigen-specific activation t-cells
clonally expand
upregulate activation markers and
release cytokines
thus assessment of those markers and
cytokines as well as proliferation are
valuable tools
for the analysis of antigen-activated
t-cells
some molecules are of outstanding
importance when it comes to diesel
activation and serve as good activation
indicators
cd69 as an early pawn diesel activation
marker
cd25 the il2 receptor
has a later activation marker on all
conventional t
cells but also as regulatory diesel
marker
cd 137 also called 41vb
a suitable cd8 positive conventional
diesel activation marker
but also as early activation marker on
regulatory t
cells and cd 154
also called cd40 ligand as ideal
conventional
cd4 t cell activation marker with a very
low background
and finally of course cytokines for the
functional analysis
of the antigen activated t cells
generally analysis methods for antigen
specific t cells can be classified into
two categories first
the direct analysis methods
labeling of the specific tcr using
recombinant mhc peptide multimeters
identifies specific t cells directly
according to the
specific antigen receptor without
restriction to a certain functional
parameter
hereby class 1 mhc peptide multimeters
are widely used to quantify
and characterize antigen-specific
cd8-positive diesel responses
the construction of class 2 multimeters
for cd4 diesel analysis is more
difficult
due to differences of the mhc structure
and tcr affinity
however recently as some advancements
have been
made in this field still this method is
more frequently applied to cd8 positive
tesol analysis
and lacks somewhat cd4 t cell
applicability
however the major limitation of the
tetramere or multimeter technology
is that the antigenic epitope has to be
characterized in detail
that is a defined peptide restricted to
a particular
mhc haplotype
second we have the indirect analysis
methods
this category employs functional
parameters such as expression of
aforementioned activation markers and
cytokines
but also cytotoxicity and proliferation
as an indirect readout
for t cells which react to a specific
antigen challenge
the detection of antigen-specific t
cells by functional parameters requires
the prior in vitro stimulation with the
specific antigen
for stimulation peptides peptide pools
proteins or lysates can be used
covering here by all possible t cell
epitopes
the advantage of these activation
methods is that
they are independent of mhc alleles or
exact
definition of the antigenic epitopes
however the assays depend on the
presence of a sufficient number of
functional antigen presenting cells
and per definition exclude energy key
cells from the analysis
most importantly the biggest advantage
here is that
all relevant information can be obtained
using flow cytometry based essays
and selective markers allow for
additional cell isolation or enrichment
in the following slides we will
especially have a look at the indirect
analysis methods
for antigen specific t cells to have a
complete view on the functional
characteristics of these interesting
cells
however as advanced the different
approaches for the analysis of
antigen-specific t-cells are
there are quite some challenges that
need to be faced
the most difficult challenge of course
is the rarity of t
cells of a given specificity depending
on the individual experience of the
donor
as well as of the antigen itself
frequencies can vary between 0.1 percent
down to 0.001 percent of the whole
t-cell population
in addition to that sometimes those rare
cells are difficult to isolate
for example when working with solid
tissue
also it needs to be determined which
cytokines and markers one wants actually
to look at
here again the specific circumstances
and goals need to be taken into
consideration
we will have a closer look at these
challenges learn about individual
experimental solutions
and have examples of successful
applications
in the end it is indeed like finding the
needle in the haystack
as outlined before the frequency of
antigen-specific t-cells can vary
depending on the circumstances
and is one of the biggest challenges for
the analysis
all the more it is important to
optimally prepare the starting material
without losing pressure cells
furthermore only a low background
enables to efficiently
find the desired cell population as it
helps to drastically increase
sensitivity in detection
of course specific labeling no matter if
for the cell enrichment or flow analysis
is essential to lower the background
to efficiently isolate detect and
analyze antigen-specific t
cells an optimized procedure during
every step of the workflow is essential
from sample preparation to cell culture
to enrichment and finally to flow
analysis
multinate biotech combines different
technologies over the whole workflow
to maximize success when working with
rare antigen-specific t-cells
the whole workflow of course should be
optimized and the right product
combination
is the key
however why are especially t cells so
fundamental for an efficient antivirus
response
apart from the innate immunity and
b-cell-mediated antibody response
t-cells play a central role in the
body's antivirus defense
for example by killing of virus infected
cells directly
but also by supporting the visa response
all these parts of the human immune
response are complementary for an
efficient antivirus immune response
consequently only assessing antibody
serology does
not give the full picture the very
specific tissue response has
also to be analyzed
from infectious diseases and viruses
like mers
and sarskoff 1 that are closely related
to covid19
we know of the important role of
virus-specific t
cells for an efficient antivirus immune
response
as xao at al state in science immunology
as well as other recent publications the
role of t cells
in coronavirus related infection these
infectious diseases
is essential for the analysis of the
population's immune status in
epidemiological studies the prognosis
for disease progress and treatment
options for virus infections
for long-term protection provided by
virus-specific memory t
cells as a target point for vaccine
development
and finally also for monitoring the
efficacy of a vaccine
please follow the links on the upper and
lower right side to find the respective
publications in pubmed
however to analyze the rare virus
specific t
cells efficiently several parameters
have to be fulfilled
sensitivity for the most precise results
speed for higher throughput simple
procedures
for a lower error rate a multi-parameter
analysis
for all crucial factors and
reproducibility
for higher reliability and miltoni
biotech has of course the fitting
solutions
so let's have a look at the in vitro
workflow when analyzing antigen-specific
t-cells
first pbmcs including t cells are
isolated from a donor sample
however in any case antigen presenting
cells need to be present to prime the t
cells with the given antigen within the
pbmc context this is
already the case consequently when
working with isolated t
cells added antigen presenting cells
have to be co-cultured
next the cells are stimulated with the
antigen of interest
for example using virus peptide pools
after a stimulation phase of several
hours the antigen specific t cells get
activated
upregulate certain surface markers and
secrete functional cytokines
now cells can be stained intra and
extracellularly
to assess phenotype on cytokine
expression
additionally secreted cytokines can be
analyzed in the cell calcium
supernatants
before the analysis rare
antigen-specific t cells
may be pre-enriched finally
cells can now be analyzed by a flow
cytometry
to assess the quality and functionality
of the antigen-specific t-cell response
a successful experimental workflow
starts with efficient sample preparation
the most widely used source for
antigen-specific t-cells are pbmcs
they contain both the antigen-specific
t-cells as well as the antigen
presenting cells
and thereby provide a functional
immunological context
for the analysis of antigen-activated
t-cells
usually pbmcs are prepared via density
gradient centrifugation
however when working with for example
compromised samples
contaminated samples very spare
small samples or very rare cells density
gradient centrifugation can be very
tedious
inefficient inefficient and even
dangerous
here recovery of every cell counts
with the pbmc isolation kit small blood
volumes ranging from 1 to 10 milliliters
can be easily processed within 25
minutes
to obtain highly pure pbmcs with a high
recovery
the maxprep pbmc isolation kit
eliminates user dependent
inconsistencies
and performs reliably for every
separation
and is a very valuable solution
please follow the link in the
sub-headline to get the respective
product page however
under certain disease conditions tissue
infiltrating antigen-specific t-cells
might be of interest
in this step valuable cells can be
easily lost due to inefficient tissue
dissociation
or harsh digest conditions
especially with the rare cells again
every prepared cell counts
our hallmark product here is the
gentlemax tissue dissociator
the gentle disassociation preserves cell
epitopes and recovers efficiently
precious immune cells
even from hard to process tissue samples
being programmable the performance is
highly reproducible
it is fast since with the gentlemax up
to 8 samples can be processed in
parallel
with the heaters you can control the
temperature for optimal performance
and finally with the sterile enclosed
tubes you work in a safe and closed
system
the perfect addition to the gentlemax
are our tissue dissociation kits
they combine enzymatic treatment with
the gentlemax mechanical
dissociation t-cells can be isolated
with ease
even from difficult human and mouse
tissue such as spleen
tumor lung liver skin brain
and lung inappropria
the combination of the gentle max
dissociate and the tissue dissociation
kits
guarantee high yield best
reproducibility
and most gentle dissociation for the
preservation of epitopes
and thereby optimal recovery of rare and
delicate cells
please again follow the link in the
sub-headline to get to the respective
product page
after preparing target cells for example
pbmcs
a crucial step in the workflow is the
antigen-specific stimulation of the
t-cells
hereby the most efficient
antigen-specific stimulation of t-cells
is achieved reliably with our peptiviter
peptide pools
these extensive panels of virus tumor
fungi
or microbiota specific antigens consists
of 50 meropeptides with 11 amino acid
overlaps
covering the complete sequence of the
respective antigen
the peptide composition ensures the
optimal stimulation of both cd4
and cd8 t cells moreover
milton is peptivators are water soluble
and do not have to be diluted in harmful
dmso
peptides are available in different
quality grades as well as in a
convenient 96 well format for high
throughput
applications the different poly
quality grades include research grade
premium grade and
even max gmp grade most notably
we recently added sarskoff 2 protein s
protein n and protein m peptides to our
portfolio to support your research
best in these difficult times please
follow the respective links to get to
the peptivada product pages
as listed here the many specificities
for our peptivator peptide pools
cover the most important antigens
ranging from various viruses
such as cmv and ebv of course also
including sarskoff
ii to for example gp100
melania two candida albicans as well as
to auto antigens like insulin
on the right side you can see how
efficiently peptivator peptide pools
stimulate cd4 and cd8 t
cells hereby assessed by interferon
gamma expression after stimulation
peptide as ht provide quality synthetic
peptide pools
to enable high throughput applications
assemble your customized sa by simply
combining modular
specific strips on a single plate
this level of absolute flexibility
leaves you in full control
of your experimental setup
a control strip can also be easily added
more flexibility
greater convenience and comprehensive
support for the
from the experts in t cells
of course flow cytometry is the most
widely used method to analyze
antigen and virus-specific t-cells
however even an established method like
flow cytometry
has its limits and challenges as
antigen-specific t-cells can be
extremely rare and evade detection
as described by bhagat colleagues in
current opinions of pharmacology
in 2015 despite its high sensitivity
standard flow cytometry is limited by
the number of events
which can be acquired typically around 1
million cells
as well as the staining background which
is typically between 0.01 and 0.1
percent
this restricts the analysis to
populations occurring at frequencies
lower than 0.01 percent
to 0.1 percent in absence of acute
infections
frequency of antigen-specific memory
cells can typically
be in the range of one cell within 100
to one cell within 100 000
however many functionally important t
cell populations
occur at much lower frequencies for
example t cells specific for certain
viruses
auto antigens tumor antigens
environmental antigens or neo antigens
are typically below 0.01 percent
they cannot be assessed without
additional measures
such as pre-enrichment and reduction of
the flow background
so of course ideally use max microbeads
for the pre-enrichment
moreover to keep background during flow
analysis to a minimum
specific labeling and bright
fluorophores are a prerequisite
the use of reaffinity recombinant
antibodies and our bright propriety
biodie conjugates
maximizes these efforts later we will
hear more about that
you can also follow the link in the two
last bullet points to get more info
about reaffinity recombinant antibodies
and our biodies
so what makes our microbeads max
technology so special
and the ideal tool for the
pre-enrichment of rare and fragile cells
the gold standard so to say under the
motto
select the best we describe the
advantage of our column technology
minimal labeling with no effects on cell
biology for full downstream
compatibility the column
amplifies the magnetic field 10 000 fold
this allows for minimal labeling in
smallest bead size
in consequence less epitopes are covered
on the cell surface
and less stress is applied on the cells
the color matrix allows for the most
gentle sorting since there is a large
space between the steel spheres around
20 times the size of a single lymphocyte
and thousands of publications agree
and on the right side you can see the
consequences
the more left panel shows color-free
technology with massive
over labeling and bead aggregates
the panel more on the right shows max
column technology
minimal labeling and smallest bead size
if you like to learn more about max cell
separation technology please follow the
link above
and indeed the results with our
enrichment cd 154 and cd 137 micro bit
kits are striking
pbmcs were stimulated to cmv pp65
peptides or left untreated
and then gen antigen activated t cells
were enriched using our cd 154 and cd
137 micro bit kits respectively
cells were then counter stains for cd4
and cd8
as expected hardly any cell expressing
154 or cd 137
can be found in the unstimulated samples
regardless of enrichment
after stimulation however antigen
specific t cells heavily upregulate the
respective markers
and can thereby be easily enriched for
any downstream analysis
with the ccd 137 and cd 154 microbeads
miltoni biotech offers the ideal tools
to pre-enrich activated antigen-specific
t cells
highest purity and recovery are ensured
with the minimal labeling
full compatibility to all downstream
applications without
effects on a cell biology is ensured
of course the tesa related cell
separation portfolio is not limited
to cd 154 and cd 137
but comprises solutions for the positive
and negative isolation
of several t cell subsets including cd4
t cells cda t cells and t rex cells
make sure to have a look at the
respective technology paper by following
the respective link on the lower right
side
in this context the rapid rt protocol is
the perfect solution
it combines surface marker staining with
intracellular cytogram staining
but includes also an enrichment step
based on cd 154
expression for even the rarest antigen
specific cd4 positive t cells
first pbmcs are stimulated with a
specific antigen
for some hours the t cells get activated
and upregulate accordingly activation
marker
cd 154 and release functional cytokines
cells are then stained for further
surface markers
including cd 154
next cells are enriched via cd 154
using max columns and further
intracellular staining for example for
cytokines
are performed directly on the column
then the enriched and stained
antigen-activated t cells can be eluted
and easily analyzed via flow cytometry
in for example on our muxquant analyzer
this approach is not only very fast
with this time staining directly on the
column but
also extremely sensitive due to the
enrichment by a cd 154
cd 154 is as described before an
activation marker that is ideally suited
to enrich
rare antigen activated ct4 positive t
cells rapid rt may be modified for cd8
positive t
cells by using other markers for example
cd 137 for enrichment
in this example here that you can see on
the right side as described by bhagat
colleagues
pbmcs were stimulated with aspergillus
lysate for 7 hours
stained for surface markers and
cytokines and enriched based on their cd
154 expression
the protocol enriched antigen-specific
t-cells
up to 85 times and thereby facilitated a
reliable analysis
of aspergillus reacting t cells
rapidart is the fastest and easiest
solution for the analysis of even the
rarest of antigen-specific t-cells
with frequencies below 0.01 percent of
total t
cells please also download the
application node rapidarte
on our t-cell application page by
following the link in the upper right
side
however let's have a look at a
virus-specific example where the rta
protocol was applied
bbmc is from covid19 survivors and
healthy donors were either stimulated
with a mix of starscoff ii peptidators
a mix of influenza peptides
as controlled or left untreated
as seen in the middle panel the very
rare saskov2 specific cd4 positive
thesis
were successfully enriched via cd 154
and visualized in flow analysis
the data was provided by the courtesy of
alexander sheffeld and peter bacha
from the uk uksh in kiel germany
furthermore i want to point out a cell
separation product that
is absolutely unique the cytokine
secretion assays
they allow to detect and enrich viable
cytokine secreting cells from mouse and
human samples
cytokines are immobilized on the surface
of the secreting cells
by the so-called catch reagent basically
thereby the cells label themselves
with its own cytokines in a second step
the immobilized cytokines are then
labeled by a floor of four conjugated
antibodies
called detection reagent and can then be
detected
viably without introspecting in the flow
cytometer
in an optional third step the
fluorophore-labeled cytokine secreting
cells
can be specifically enriched and used in
downstream assays by using an
antifluorophore magnetic microbead
consequently our cytokine secretion
assays come in two versions
for flow detections only we have the
detection kits
for the separation of viable cytokine
security cells
we have the detection and enrichment
kits including the additional enrichment
step
via the max column as you can see the
cytokine secretion assay
detection and enrichment kits work very
efficiently to enrich
viable virus-specific t-cells based on
their cytokine secretion
pbmcs of a cmv positive donor were
stimulated for 4 hours with cmv
lysate the responding cells were then
stained and isolated according to the
secretion of tnef alpha
and interferon gamma using the
respective secretion essay cell
enrichment and detection kits
as you can see in the stimulated samples
a strong population of cytokines
secreting cd4
and cd8 positive t cells respectively
was enriched
in the unstimulated control sample
however no cytokine secreting t
cells were detected after enrichment
as briefly mentioned before talking
about flow analysis of rare
antigen-specific t cells
one of the most important aspects is the
minimization of background
here the reaffinity recombinant
antibodies are the ideal tool
being recombinantly engineered we have
complete control over the sequence and
guarantee
highest purity and lotto lot consistency
to significantly reduce background
hereby the fc receptor binding site was
mutated
so no unspecific specific fc binding
occurs and tedious fcr blocking can be
completely omitted
combined with our super bright propriety
biodyes
for clear population discrimination you
have the ideal and most precise tool for
flow analysis of rare cells
please again follow the respective links
to find more product informations as
well as our useful tool
the antibody panel builder to design
well-planned complex multi-color panels
with optimized flow cytometry antibodies
however we do not only look
at antibodies but also
have ready-to-use flow analysis kits
ranging from pre-mixed antibody cocktail
to full-fledged in-depth kits
the rapid cytokine inspector combines
extracellular diesel markers
staining with intracellular cytokine
staining for the analysis of
activated cd4 and cd8 positive t
cells the maxplex assays
are designed for determining
concentrations of up to 12 soluble
analytes in a single sample
for example secreted cytokines in cell
culture supernatants
and last but not least the eight-color
immunophenotyping kit human
allows from the evaluation of various
leukocyte subsets in
one kit for example monocytes
neutrophils
eosinophils tb and nk cell populations
and of course all of these gates are
compatible with the fast
and convenient express modes on the max
quant analyzers
automating analysis and thereby not only
speeding it up
but also eliminating human errors
however we will later hear more about
that
make sure to have a look at the
respective promo video by following the
respective links in the right side
let's have a closer look at some of
these flow kits
for the mere flow staining without
enrichment of antigen-specific t-cells
the rapid cytokine inspector is the
ideal all-in-one kit
for the combined extra intracellular
staining of antigen-specific t-cells
thereby subtype and activation-specific
surface markers
as well as intracellular cytokines are
stained at the same time
the rapid cytokine inspector is ideal to
monitor antigen-specific
cells with frequencies higher than 0.01
percent of the total tcp population
as said before for lower frequencies the
rapid rt protocol including the
enrichment step
is recommended applications for the
rapid cytokine inspector include
assessment of samples immune status or
testing of ligapheresis material
for virus-specific cd4 and cd8-positive
t-cells
on the right side you can see how the
rapid cytokine inspector was compared
to standard intracellular staining
protocols
after the stimulation with cmv peptides
pp65
and ie frequencies of cmv specific cd4
and cd8 t cells were analyzed in pbmcs
thereby for example the frequency of
virus specific t cells in
euclidean products as said before can be
assessed
the rapid cytokine inspector performed
as good as the classical intracellular
staining
but yields the benefits of a much faster
protocols
and then less washing steps and thereby
less cell
loss as said before
the rapid cytokine inspectors is of
course compatible with the express modes
for automated data analysis on the
maxquant analyzers
this example shows the successful
analysis of antigen-specific
cd8-positive theses producing interferon
gamma and il-2
after peptivator stimulation human pbmcs
were incubated with or with ours
peptivator cmb
pp65 for six hours and brevilleton a
was added after two hours the cells were
then stained using the rapid cytokine
inspector for expression of cd8
interferon gamma and interleukin-2
expression was then assessed with the
max quant analyzer 10.
as you can see the stimulated cmv
specific cd8 positive t cells nicely
expressed
c interferon gamma and il2 upon
activation
finally we'd like to show you an example
where cd3 positive t cells were assessed
for interferon gamma
expression after stimulation with our
sarskoff 2 peptivators
a blood sample was lysed within rbc
lysis buffer and stimulated for four
hours with the respective peptides
or left untreated subsequently cells
were stained using the rapid cytokine
inspector-based staining protocol
interferon gamma production by
cd3-positive t-cells was assessed
the plots clearly show that covet-19
survivors show elevated level of
sars-cof2-reactive t-cells
after stimulation with the respective
peptivators
another important aspect of antigen
activated t cell analysis
is the analysis of secreted functional
cytokines
here melting biotech offers as briefly
mentioned before
flow analysis kits for multi-parameter
analysis of soluble
cytokines in cell culture supernatants
the max black cytokine kits they are
designed for determining concentrations
of up to 12
human soluble analytes in a single
sample
the analysis is based on maxplex capture
beads
which display defined fluorescent
properties and can be identified using
any multicolor standard flow cytometer
again in combination with the express
modes on the max quant analyzers however
the maxplex cytokine kits are optimized
for automated measurements and simplify
flow cytometric analysis where
predefined experimental settings as well
as acquisition
and analysis templates furthermore
additional variants of the maxplex kits
for example for
mouse samples exosome analysis or the
analysis of cytotoxic t and nk cells are
available
so the muxplex essays allow real
multiplex assays
for secreted cytokines using any
standard flowstatometer
make sure to have also a look at the
respective webinar by following the link
on the right side
here we have an example how much plex
analysis
using the max quant express modes look
like
pbmcs were stimulated with cv peptides
and a supernatant analyzed for cytokine
secretion
the fast and easy express modes automate
analysis
of unknown samples without user
dependent variations and result in most
reproducible analysis
as you can see here within minutes a
graphical representation as well as a
statistical display of the measured
cytokines
is emitted by the software
so what are these express modes exactly
express modes are software modules on
the max1 analyzers that
automate floor analysis with
standardized algorithm-based data
evaluation
results become more standardized as
operator variability is minimized due to
a lack of manual intervention
and reduction of human error this
results in highest reproducibility with
identical flow analysis
independent from the operator
express modes are simple to use and
offer quick and robust analysis for easy
integration into sops
with the validated automated analysis
concept
several of our flow kits as the
aforementioned rapid cytokine inspector
max black cytokine kits the eight color
immunophenol typing kit as well as
specific flow panels
for example for car t cell analysis are
compatible with the express modes
again make sure to have a look at the
respective webinar by following
the respective link in the middle of the
page
in this context let's have a brief
excursion to our flow instruments from
the max quant series
first we have the max quant analyzer
powerful benchtop flow cytometers
with up to 16 optical parameters
the clue here is that they allow for
full automation
including acquisition using a robotic
sample collector with the express mode
software modules
even the data analysis is automated and
free of human error
second we have the max quant title cell
sorter
thanks to microchip sorting using a
microwolf the max plant title
allows for the most gentle cell sorting
and highest viability
even for rare and fragile cells
furthermore the closed and sterile
cartridge system
makes the title the ideal machine for a
gmp environment
it is worthwhile mentioning that of
course safety
in this kind of research comes first the
small benchtop cytometers fit
easily under the laminar flow cabinet
and the title cell sorter works without
internal fluidics
and applies a sterile enclosed cartridge
system for maximum operator safety
here i'd like to have a closer look
especially at the max quantity cell
sorter
with its unique capabilities namely the
most gentle sorting and the closed
derived cartridge system
the title is the ideal machine for a gmp
clinical environment
not only in the fields of car t cells
and t-rex but of course
also in the field of antigen specific t
cells
so let me point out that the title is
already part of several clinical
cancer trials involving antigen or
better tumor-specific t cells
as you can see in the list on the right
side
of course i want to share an application
example for the sorting of cmv specific
cd8 positive t
cells using the title cell sorter
bbmcs from a cmv 0 positive donor were
labeled with cmv
dextramir pe and cd8apc
and sorted with the maxwell title the
dot plot shows
pre-bmc's prior to sorting in the input
chamber
this cmv decks from a positive target
cell fraction after sorting in the
positive collection chamber
and the cell fraction depleted of the
cmv dextrovia
positive cells in the negative
collection chamber
flow cytometry analysis was then
performed on the max quant analyzer
as you can see cmv specific cd8 positive
t cells were gently sorted with highest
purity to
of almost 94 percent
make sure to have a look at the
respective application node
and scientific poster by following the
respective links on the right side
to this end here you see a schematic
overview of our whole antigen-specific
test portfolio and workflow
from sample preparation to cell
separation to cell analysis we cover the
whole antigen-specific t-cell workflow
please make sure to have a look at our
respective application website
for the virus-specific t-cells as well
as our webinar by following the links
below
to sum up the most important message is
that we will manage this virus crisis
together
t cells play a fundamental role in the
antivirus immune response and their
analysis in this context
is very important there are a lot of
benefits from an efficient
virus-specific tesa research
apart from a better understanding of the
antivirus immune response
t-cell analysis in this context may
clarify important questions like
if reinfections are possible if other
corona infections might provide immunity
or which role secondary diseases might
play
furthermore analysing t cells in viral
infections will allow
a more exact prognosis on disease
progression
opening thereby a more reliable
assessment of action options
and may lead to better planning and
therefore hopefully a faster return to a
habitual life
resulting in also minimization of
economic damages
but most importantly we cover the whole
antigen and virus-specific t-cell
workflow
to assist you in your research
please also acknowledge the displayed
disclaimer
with this i come to an end of this
presentation thank you very much
for your attention and stay healthy
thank you dr stein for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first
question is do you have any quantitative
data
on enrichment of other rare cells from
blood
such as ctc or cfc
um hello everybody so um no
at the moment we have not uh
quantitative data in regards to those
cells we actually
here are focusing on the antigen
specific t cells that exhibit
cd 154 and 137
enrichment we usually add multibiotic
and focus on you know different cd
markers to do so
so if you have a marker that
that you want to enrich or if you want
to enrich those cells
by specific markers then um
of course you can you can have a look if
you have the respective enrichment kit
and there you will find for sure
quantity of data
thank you dr stein next question
is it possible to stimulate enriched
cd4 t cells with virus
peptides without using apc
cell so
actually i'd say no you need
an antigen presenting cells or at least
some way of antigen presentation that
presents the respective
peptides to the t cells and provides
an additional stimulus so we always
recommend
to use pvmcs in this context
or to actually use isolated t-cells
together with for example
monocyte-derived dendritic cells as apcs
in a co-culture
this is a relatively clean system where
you will get
the the reaction that you're looking for
of course um it has to be autonomous
then
okay what is the proportion
of ifng in enrichment
cd4 t cell
um i guess you're
saying how many cells
in the enrichment are interferon gamma
positive
so actually um i
would need to look that up what our
average is i mean you can see it from
the clock
what it is but actually you can see
there are no
numbers provided for this
i would either recommend that you have a
look on our website
to find um the respective kit
and then there for sure our plot
displayed where we have percentage
um or you can simply
call our maxtec hotline and ask them for
this specific block what the percentage
was and they will instantly answer you
and give you the percentage
okay thank you okay let's see
here's an interesting question due to
the
relatively low affinity of
auto antibody and autoimmune disease
do you have recommended uh
trying to print oh miltoni kits that
could be used to
isolate or recognize antigen specific t
cells in autoimmune disease
that's indeed an interesting question
so most of our data and this is also the
topic of this talk was generated with
virus-specific t-cells and there
the question is a little bit different
of course because depending on which
virus we are talking about so
cv for example they're still the cells
are rare but not
as rare and
[Music]
the um auto antigen specific key so
that's absolutely true
so i'd say this is something you have
to try out this would be absolutely my
first recommendation
and in any case for those
types of cells you need to do with a
very efficient pre-enrichment so
if you prepare your pbmcs
and then you stimulate with your auto
antigen
and then you have a very very rare
population of reactive cells
then go via the pre-enrichment depends a
little bit if it's cd4 cd8 cells if
the fossil then with cd 154
pre-enrichment
you should be very well able to
pre-enrich
enough so that you even though the cells
are extremely
rare will be able to detect them for the
cd8 cells
either try rapid arc we're modifying it
by using cd 137 or directly go on the
sales order
with a fail sorter and appropriate
amount of starting cells
or bbmcs then even with the results
should be good
thank you what is the difference
between max quant analyzer and
taito the
analyzer is a flow cytometer
and the title is a flow sorter
the max current analyzer comes in
different versions so we have the max
point analyzer 10 with 10 optical
parameters we have the max quant
analyzer 16
with 16 octave parameters we have the
max current wipe
that has a different laser setup for
especially
good for me for for for cherry
dye analysis and we have the max quant
x which is a high throughput
flow analyzer so the analyzers the max
quant
analyzers the slow cytometers coming
four versions the maxquan title
for now is just one version and only the
title is a cell sorter
okay next question okay let's see
can we use ls column for negative
isolation
of cd4 t cells from
pbmc
uh yes so there are several several
approaches it depends a little bit
on the on the starting amount of
cells that you have um
so if you work with higher amounts
one kind of um
column is is maybe suited if you work
lower amount another kind of column is
issued but generally yes you can do that
but i would
always recommend that you go for
the data sheet of the respective kits
because there are exceptions generally
so sometimes you want to deplete you
would not use an ls column you would use
an ld column for example
but the datasheet always gives you the
the recommendation of which color you
have to use
okay thank you dr stein we have time for
one more question and the final question
for today is
an analogy to
cytokine i i apologize if i'm saying
that incorrectly
capture essays can you also capture
antigen specific antibodies on the
surface of viable b
cells no
unfortunately not yet so this is eclipse
that we do not
have in our portfolio yet but it's a
very interesting
idea
thank you again dr stein for um for your
wonderful presentation do you have any
final comments for our audience today
um just thank you all for listening stay
healthy and to you tracy thank you very
much for your support
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and again for their interesting
questions questions that we did not have
time for today
and those that are submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
we would like to thank you dr stein for
your time today in your important
research
and we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor
miltoni biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
yep lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues and friends who may
have missed today's live event
until next time thank you again everyone
and goodbye